[Music]
he should be remembered as a happy baby
yeah
nothing more nothing less and he is not
suffering
no more loved ones and strangers coming
together tonight to remember amari
nicholson
a vigil was held at the complex where he
lived it's not far from the spot that
police
found his body today we do thank you for
joining us on 8 news now at 11 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez the community
coming out in large
numbers to show support for amari's
family tonight as they begin their fight
for justice
we have team coverage tonight sasha
loftis spoke with valley mothers who
felt compelled to honor the little boy
but we start with orco mana with how
family friends are
planning to try to move forward orca
well brian and denise loved ones are
still numb tonight they can't believe
amari is gone
but they're honoring his life and legacy
with these balloons
candles flowers and messages as they
grapple with grief
their focus now is on getting justice
for it to be so close to home it hurts
loved ones light candles the flickering
flames spelling out the name
amari the two-year-old boy whose bright
light was put out far
too soon to fight for him
close family friends remembering him as
a beautiful boy and special soul
he was a happy baby he should be
remembered as a happy baby
nothing more nothing less and he is not
suffering
no more the shock and sadness is still
setting
in omaree's body was found wednesday
causing overwhelming emotion
but not enough closure anger confusion
a little bit of peace a little bit of
peace but
you may still want to know why yeah and
how could somebody hurt an innocent baby
as they searched for answers those who
knew amari are trying to figure out what
to do
now that he is no longer with us go home
pray
talk you know talk to omaree just
hopefully he's looking down on all of us
family and friends are bracing for the
days and weeks ahead and they're relying
on their faith to give amari the justice
he deserves give it to god at the end of
the day
it's god has the last word has a last
day
loved ones tell us they're focusing now
on the legal process
and say they'll do whatever they have to
do to make sure amari's killer
stays behind bars reporting live in las
vegas tonight
orco mana 8 news now